oh
tu sais ce qui est parfait aujourd'hui
tout ouais
[Musique] très
bien comment se passe la surveillance du quartier
laisse-moi voir ce qui se passe
rien de
rose
je ne déteste pas c'est
un peu rêveur fais ça
comment peuvent-ils se permettre tout ça d'accord les
garçons on s'en va  pour travailler, ne pas avoir
trop de soleil Bonne chance pour diriger le monde,
amusez-vous dans l'espace
wow, ces gens n'ont pas compris
ouais, ils peuvent avoir leurs manoirs et leurs
emplois d'astronaute parce que nous aurons toujours de la
pizza, hé, assez assis, préparons-nous
[Musique]
hé mon frère, as-tu filmé ça, désolé, je suis
censé filmer tout ce que tu fais
parce que beaucoup de choses sont stupides
[Musique] qu'est-
ce que tu regardes, qu'est-ce que tu
regardes, bonjour les
gars, celui-là a l'air
cool, bruh Broski
abracadabra
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
allez, je suis un câlin, entrez ici, je vais y arriver, allez,
n'arrêtez pas de serrer
tout le monde dans vos bras, non
[Musique]